for over 40 years there's only one place
that can claim the careers of today's
biggest comedians what started as a
small french-speaking Festival in the
early 80s is now comedy's biggest event
averaging over 2 million attendees this
is where the top comedians industry and
fans unite I'm talking about just for
laughs in Montreal
but what makes this Festival so special
this is the mecca for everything comedy
there isn't anybody from around the
world in comedy that hasn't performed
here that hasn't produced something here
or hasn't been seen and discovered here
just for Laughs new faces has propelled
more comedian careers than anywhere else
on the planet but they have bigger plans
than just American comedians we've added
a couple years ago Canada new faces this
year we've added International faces to
make sure true to our DNA we launch
Canadians but we also launched the world
we're not just an American Star Comedy
Festival we're an international Comedy
Festival there are a lot of famous
comments to get their break at just for
last but it doesn't get much bigger than
Kevin Hart so what makes Just for Laughs
such a big deal I'm I mean for me it's
been a big deal because it's had a lot
to do with the projection of my career
we literally really started together yes
we were in the Montreal Just for Laughs
Festival in new faces which is a
category they have at this big Festival
clap your hands stop being racist clap
your hands
before JFL Kevin Hart was a hustling
comic just trying to make ends meet
after JFL he left with a 275 thousand
dollar holding deal with NBC this
overnight transformation is perfectly
highlighted in his book the chapter
before JFL is greatest pilot that no
one's seen during JFL how it became an
international superstar in Canada and
after JFL oh my God I'm rich but Kev is
not an outlier at finding Fame and just
for laughs Dave Chappelle is another
comedy Titan that credits JFL for his
success just for last it's probably the
single biggest break in my career I'm
very grateful to them because they set
me on a trajectory to be better than a
good comedian Dave's first time
performing at JFL was in 1993 and the
president of the festival Bruce Hills
remembers it like it was yesterday
there's no question when you watch a VHS
at 11 o'clock at night on a Tuesday of
Dave Chappelle doing three separate sets
in his teens from three shitty TV shows
and three amazing different sets that
were provocative or hilarious were super
intelligent his point his performance
was superb I just called the phone
number on the VHS to guy didn't know and
just said I'm taking I mean I never book
someone on the spot it was so obvious I
was just so curious to understand who
this kid was he was just so so
incredible
they love Montreal
I do man
yeah man I was hanging out in the black
community today both of those guys are
great
I don't know how many of you have ever
been to just for last Festival but you
guys have a National Treasure here
you sincerely dude Jerry Seinfeld
performed at the festival in 1989 and
that same year his TV show was released
Jimmy Fallon performed in 1995 got a
development deal SNL and then The
Tonight Show but in recent years
comedians are catching their breaks more
online than at these in-person festivals
and you best believe JFL has noticed
they are making a big push into the
social media game so much so they have a
new owner it's JFL Alum Howie Mandel and
he has some big plans there's so many
platforms that are available to us like
Facebook and Instagram and Twitter and
twitch where we can be a little more
interactive and hashtag JFL and those
things could just explode so that for
the people that aren't here in the
moment they go oh my God this is what's
trending this is what's happening where
is that how can I interact how can I be
part of it back in 1988 JFL did a live
broadcast on HBO that helped them get a
lot of new fans and they're hoping to do
the same now but online the new digital
content sketch show shows and live
podcasts
which I'm gonna get hot breath in there
well the best comic to learn social
media from is Andrew Schultz which is
why I made this video to give you all
his secrets
enjoy
oh I was gonna have confetti this is
gonna be great
you know
you